que deviendra l'ancienne halle du marché
communal une des questions d'aménagement
de la ville après la réhabilitation des
écoles place à la problématique de
sécurité aux abords mais aussi dans la
ville faut-il poursuivre le déploiement
de la vidéoprotection les objectifs de
logements sociaux ne sont pas encore
totalement rempli dans la commune il est
de 24,6 % pour un objectif fixé par la
loi de 25% d'ici 2025 les 0,4 pour cent
représente une cinquantaine de logements
aux clayes-sous-bois des futurs
logements vont sortir de terre en 2021
autre enjeu un manque de stationnement
dans le centre ville mais aussi autour
de l'espace socioculturel philippe
noiret beaucoup sont devenus payants
même problématique aux alentours du
centre commercial one nacion qui possède
la plus grande parapharmacie outlet de
france où la circulation est dense
le centre devra faire face à la future
concurrence du centre commercial
openskies a plaisir à contrario les clés
siens espèrent des embauches avec
l'ouverture de ce centre opensky prévue
pour avril 2020 autre chantier le centre
de recherche et développement en date
hausse devrait se conclure à l'été 2020
leur mission l'innovation dans le
domaine de l'ordinateur quantique et de
la cybersécurité 100 emplois seront
créés enfin une crainte pour les
habitants la diminution du nombre de
praticiens et les départs en retraite
non remplacés la création d'une maison
de santé pluridisciplinaire est
souhaitée pour pallier cette pénurie de
médecins